The United States has stopped winning wars.
It has stopped winning wars since World War
II.
And the question is, why have we stopped winning
wars?
We have the best troops, we have the best
equipment, we have the best technology, we
have the most money.
So what's the problem?
But since World War II, you know, Korea is
a stalemate, Vietnam went communist.
There's Afghanistan, Iraq these are failures.
We must be honest with ourselves, these are
failures.
But this is not just a US problem.
The West, quote unquote, writ large, does
not know how to win wars anymore.
Look at France in Indochina and Algeria; the
British in Palestine and Cyprus; the Soviets
in Afghanistan; Israel against Hezbollah in
Lebanon.
The question is, what does it mean if the
West can no longer win wars?
It's an obvious question, but nobody wants
to ask it because the implications are too
terrifying to behold.
And the answer is: war has moved on.
War has changed.
It has new rules, and it looks nothing like
World War II, which is our model, our strategic
paradigm.
And as long as we keep this up, we will continue
to have forever wars.
One of the new rules of war is that we will
see the return of mercenaries, of private
force, of private warfare.
You know, they say mercenary is the second
oldest profession.
Private war has been around for a very long
time, but we've forgotten it.
Mercenaries have only been sort of underground
for 150 years.
Now they're coming back.
And most of military history is private military
history.
The reason it's come back is because the US
resurrected it, ironically, with the Iraq
and Afghan wars.
The US it's ironic because it's the superpower
that did this.
It wasn't small states with money who needed
an army that didn't have it, it was the United
States of America.
And the reason the US did this is because
they initially, policymakers thought the Iraq
war and the Afghanistan war would be very
short, easy wars.
And we remember Secretary Defense Rumsfeld
saying that these wars would take days, weeks
at most, certainly not months.
Now it's nearly 20 years later, and we're
still mired in these quagmires.
We're still stuck in these entrenched places
in South Asia and the Middle East.
One of the solutions that's being considered
is replacing all American troops in Afghanistan
by mercenaries.
This is currently what President Trump is
considering doing, led by Erik Prince.
Erik Prince is the founder of Blackwater.
Blackwater was a large private military company
that, in 2007, massacred 17 civilians in Baghdad,
and it became one of the low points of the
Iraq war.
He is the sister of Betsy DeVos, the Secretary
of Education, and is using political connections
for the biggest paycheck of his career.
Now, this would normally be a laughable situation,
right?
Replacing, you know, American troops with
mercenaries.
What makes it even more laughable and even
dangerous is that he thinks that 6,500 mercenaries
can fix Afghanistan.
Now, at the height of the Afghan war, there
was 140,000 NATO troops in Afghanistan, which
couldn't do anything, really, in Afghanistan.
And now, the Taliban control more of Afghanistan.
So what is Erik Prince going to do with 6,500?
That's a good question.
What is even more dangerous, though, is what
happens to war when you privatize it.